Hey, I have some really interesting video
for you.
Elizabeth Warren appeared on the view yesterday.
The view is this, a multi host talk show that's
really become a pretty prominent place for
democratic candidates.
Really for news makers of all kinds of elected
officials, celebrities, whatever.
But the democratic candidates have been stopping
at the view and talking about their campaign
platforms and why they believe they should
be the 2020 democratic presidential nominee.
The hosts are sort of politically diverse.
The notable right-winger on the show is the
daughter of the late Republican Senator John
McCain, Megan McCain, and she mixes it up
with some of the left-leaning guests.
So yesterday Elizabeth Warren appears a democratic
Senator from Massachusetts running for president.
And one of her notable policies, one of her
most well known policy proposals as part of
our campaign platform is the wealth tax attacks.
That would be a 2% tax on wealth above and
beyond 50 million us dollars.
And she was on the view and joy Bay har wanting
to hear about the wealth tax and wanted to
say, how will it work?
Will it affect the middle class?
And Megan McCain kept trying to interrupt
and Elizabeth Warren takes the approach of
pretend I can't hear a word she sang.
And as Megan McCain is increasingly and visibly
frustrated with being unable to get a question
into Elizabeth Warren.
Elizabeth Warren just keeps talking, steamrolling
Megan McCain and Megan McCain becomes visibly
annoyed with this.
It's an interesting strategy.
So let's take a look at the video.
You'll be able to get most of what is going
on from the audio as well.
You'll hear Megan McCain continually trying
to talk, so it'll start with joy Bay.
Har asking Elizabeth Warren about the wealth
tax.
You will see and hear Megan McCain try to
interrupt multiple times and Warren just keeps
on going like a freight train.
McCain starts to interrupt about halfway through.
It doesn't go well.
Take a look.
Yeah, well let's talk a little bit about the
tax plan.
I think it's time for a wealth tax in America.
[inaudible]
on the top one 10th of 1% $50 million and
above your fortune.
In other words, your first 50 million is free
and clear, but on your 50 millions and first
dollar, you've got to pitch in 2 cents and
2 cents on every dollar after.
What about them?
Now, it's not the middle class one 10th of
1% I don't have plans to increase taxes on
the middle class.
Okay.
I figured out how to do every plan I've done
out there without increasing taxes on the
middle-class, but look at what a two-cell
wealth tax would do for us.
Universal childcare for every baby in this
country.
[inaudible]
billion dollars into our public schools make
it a real
[inaudible].
So college $50 billion for store black colleges
and universities.
[inaudible] Trump just said that we spent
$2 trillion on the military.
I said, I don't want anyone ever to ask Elizabeth
Warren how she's going to pay for medical
[inaudible]
Elizabeth Warren straight up pretending that
Megan McCain simply doesn't exist.
Megan McCain ends up sort of like the person
in the corner that nobody's listening to.
Now, I don't know if this is childish, but
I did find it very satisfying to watch Elizabeth
Warren just ignore Megan McCain and you can
agree or disagree with Elizabeth Warren's
plan for a wealth tax, but the handling of
it is just delightful here.
Now at the same time, this is a TV show and
I find it compelling the way that it was handled,
but I have no problem with challenging Elizabeth
Warren on her wealth tax.
There are arguments to be made that it's politically,
uh, unlikely to become a reality.
You can make the argument that it won't work,
whatever, right?
I mean that's all fine.
We can debate that.
That's great.
But Elizabeth Warren should be allowed to
at least explain the plan without interruption
and a lot of right-wingers, I was looking
online, a lot of right-wingers are just furious
with Elizabeth Warren saying, Warren is in
the wrong.
Warren won't let Meghan McCain speak.
Warren is the guest joy Bay.
Har asked Warren about the policy and Elizabeth
Warren is explaining it and she can't get
through her explanation without Megan McCain
interrupting three or four times.
Now, I do think that there's a lesson here
when people try to prevent you from even explaining
your position with bad faith interruption
attempts.
Maybe you just talk past them and you don't
allow them to interrupt you.
And Elizabeth Warren running a clinic on that.
There was one point at the very end of this
segment which I want to watch again with you
were Megan McCain looked so frustrated, she
actually looks off set at someone and looks
very awkward.
Check it out one more time.
I would not be surprised.
You know sometimes on these shows that I know
a lot of people who have worked on network
and television shows like this and often the
relationships between the hosts behind the
scenes get very weird and there are times
where the hosts aren't even talking to each
other except on the show and all communication
between them off the air is happening between
representatives.
I'm not saying that that's what's going on
here, but when I saw you were going to see
it here, when I saw Megan McCain look off
to the side, I in a fraction of a second,
the scenario that appeared in my mind is she
is disgusted and furious with how she is being
treated in terms of how much time she's being
given or whatever on the show.
And she looked to whoever is her representative
or whichever producer has taken her aside
and is kind of giving them the, see this is
what I'm talking about.
You've got to fix this for me.
Sort of look, could it be a complete fantasy?
But in any case, take a look at the uh, Meghan
McCain reaction here looking off stage.
But when that trust just said that we spent
$2 trillion on the military, I said, I don't
want anyone ever to ask Elizabeth Warren how
she's going to pay for medical care.
[inaudible]
yikes.
I feel like the tiniest bit bad for Megan
McCain, but come on, let Elizabeth Warren
explainer plan.
Then you can cite whatever talking point you
want to cite in opposition.
And please Ken, some Republicans, some right
wing pundits.
Please ask Trump, administration officials,
how are you going to pay for the Iran war?
Please ask them because when the left tries
to do good things, you can disagree with Elizabeth
Warren's wealth tax approach.
You can disagree with Bernie Sanders, Medicare
for all plan or whatever.
How are you going to pay for it?
We can't afford it is the, it's on repetition
from Republicans.
And when you want a pointless war to help
Donald Trump get reelected or to distract
from impeachment, it may be Rand Paul says,
we can't afford this, but come on, someone's
stand up on the right and say, how are we
going to pay for this war?
Uh, and don't do it.
By the way, in the thinly veiled, xenophobic
way, we're Tucker Carlson, DHEA.
We talked about Tucker Carlson the other night
saying this is totally misguided in Iran and
that we have domestic problems to focus on
Tucker's right, except he wants to focus on
all the wrong domestic problems, including
ones that aren't actually problems.
So I would love to see a Republican just stand
up, have a spine, and seriously say, Hey guys,
how are we going to pay for this?
How are we going to pay for this?
And does this make any sense whatsoever?
If we believe in checks and balances, I've
not seen any serious Republican politician
do that so far.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman.
Show continued
clips and coverage of all of these stories
and more.
There will be back right after the